tine le président russe a reçu hier le
premier ministre israélien naftali
bennet pas de détails sur ce que se sont
dit les deux hommes naftali bennet doit
aussi s'entretenir avec volodymyr
zelensky et de chancelier allemand
bonjour mariam piasa des est ce qu'on
peut parler d'une médiation ou d'une
tentative de médiation israélienne dans
ce conflit c'était en tout cas comme ça
que naftali bennet propose se pose en
médiateur dans cette crise avec un
ballet diplomatique dont vous l'avez dit
qu'il a mené à moscou où il a rencontré
vladimir poutine pendant trois heures on
ne sait rien de ce qu'ils se sont dit en
tout cas c'est la première fois qu'un
dirigeant étranger se rend à moscou
depuis l'invasion russe en ukraine il a
parlé également avec le président
ukrainien volodimir lnd qui il a rendu
aussi à berlin pour rencontrer le
chancelier olafsen alors détail qui a
son importance naftali bennett n'est pas
parti seul il est parti avec l'un de ses
ministres qui est russophone et qui est
originaire
originaire d'ukraine
on imagine que près ministre israélien
s'est fait l'écho aussi de messages
entre les deux parties a rapporté des a
pu rapporter des messages en tout cas le
communiqué final indique que l'objectif
commun et de je cite mettre fin à la
guerre en ukraine le plus rapidement
possible et les ukrainiens aussi salue
cette nouvelle initiative israélienne et
surtout le premier ministre naftali
bennett avant de partir à moscou s'est
entretenu avec les dirigeants
occidentaux et notamment emmanuel macron
parce qu'on ce qu'israël quelque peu
coincé entre le traditionnel allié
américain et l'ami russe exactement
alors naftali bennet c'est l'un des
rares dirigeants
proche de l'occident qui n'a pas
condamné l'invasion russe qui n'a pas
condamné la position de moscou pourquoi
parce que israël a d'un côté besoin de
la russie vous l'avez dit notamment sur
le sort de l'iran il en a été beaucoup
question à moscou parce qu'en ce moment
se joue à vienne le dernier rendant tout
cas c'est ce qu'on espère c'est ce que
beaucoup diplomatique espère le dernier
round de négociations sur le nucléaire
iranien pour voir ressusciter cet accord
de 2015 qui est une coquille vide depuis
le départ américain de 2018 naftali
bennett ne veut pas de cet accord il ya
deux jours il a encore dit aux
américains que c'était la pire chose qui
puisse arriver qu'il y ait de nouveau un
accord sur le crâne ya de l'autre côté
on sent bien que du côté occidental du
côté américain on veut accélérer les
choses et on voit bien que depuis samedi
vladimir poutine qui était pas proche
mais quand même qu'ils soutenaient
téhéran prend ses distances pour se
ranger du côté d'israël en disant qu'
ils demanderont à des garanties à
washington avant de signer un nouvel
accord sur le nucléaire iranien donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un petit changement
de paradigme qui est en train de se
jouer en ce moment et puisque vous
parlez de l'iran rapidement vous avez
été notre correspondante à téhéran on a
beaucoup évoqué ces sanctions
internationales l'iran sait ce que c'est
c'est sanctions internationales à quoi
risque de ressembler assez rapide dans
la vie des russes dans les prochains
jours oui effectivement la russie
rejoint le club très fermé de la corée
du nord et l'iran avec un black out
total sur les réseaux sociaux alors les
iraniens peuvent surfer sur les réseaux
sociaux mais via des vpn ce que vont
faire les russes visa et mastercard les
cartes bancaires sont en train de se
désengager de la russie c'est exactement
ce qui en iran c'est à dire que vous ne
pouvez pas tirer dans un distributeur
automatique de l'argent avec une carte
occidental il faut venir avec des sommes
importantes en liquide et trouver des
bureaux de change alors que le taux de
change varie de jour en jour forcément à
cause des sanctions c'est ce qui risque
d'arriver si ce qui va arriver aux
russes avec ces sanctions qui ont été
mises en place et qui vont en plus être
accentuée dans les prochains jours comme
l'indiqué bord et jeune saad merci
beaucoup mariam pierre godé et au front
diplomatique toujours